Immer schwierig, der Einstieg ohne ein Einstiegs-Intro. Das ist eigentlich schon fällig hier, ne?
Da müssen wir was machen.
Damit man irgendwie zu richtig in Schwung kommt und das Gefühl hat so, ah ja, jetzt.
Ja, wir sitzen hier immer und sagen so, sollen wir?
Jetzt haben wir schon angefangen. Hier ist Logbuch Netzpolitik Ausgabe Nummer 2. Wir sind immer noch sehr behäbig hier im Ansatz, um den richtigen Ton zu treffen. Und ja, freuen uns hier das erste Mal eine Fortsetzung zu machen. Das hat ja auch was. So wöchentlich ist auch eine Herausforderung. Stimmt's?
Ja.
Oh Linus, ist ja eigentlich deine Sendung, Linus. Sagen ja wieder alle, mein neuer Podcast stimmt eigentlich gar nicht. Ist ein neuer Podcast der Metaebene.
Nein, ist unsere Sendung.
Und ich, ich helfe ja nur. Jetzt lade ich die ganze Verantwortung auf deine Schultern.
Ja, das Kürzel ist ja auch Lnp. Das ist ja der Linus Neumann Podcast.
Also willkommen zum Linus Neumann Podcast.
Ja und der Linus Neumann muss direkt damit anfangen, sich für seine Fehler der ersten Sendung zu entschuldigen.
Unser Irrata.
Ja, also...
Waren es denn wirklich Fehler? Oder waren es nur wieder Sachen, die man auch hätte anders formulieren können?
Also beim ersten Mal, beim ersten Fall ist es auf jeden Fall ein Fehler. Und zwar habe ich ja gesagt, dass Alva die erste Online-Demonstration angemeldet hat. Das hat er auch. Das war also bis dahin richtig, nur dass ich gesagt habe, es war die Lufthansa-Demo. Das war katastrophal falsch. Und ich zitiere mal Wikipedia. Fälschlicherweise wird die erste Online-Demonstration häufig als eine Aktion der Initiativen Liebertat und kein Mensch ist illegal im Rahmen der antirassistischen Deportation-Class-Kampagne, die Biberpog sich gegen Abschiebungen wandte, bezeichnet. Die tatsächlich erste Online-Demonstration war aber der von Alva angemeldete Online-Protest gegen die Gesetzgebung und Haftungsregeln bezüglich Hyperlinks. Genau. Hätte ich mir eigentlich sofort denken können. Und ich bin aber ganz froh, dass selbst Wikipedia diesen Fehler so häufig ansieht, dass es einen eigenen Absatz dazu gibt, dass dieser Fehler häufig gemacht wird.
Hätte mir auch passieren können. Vielleicht ist dieser Absatz ja auch erst seit letzter Woche drin.
Ich habe ihn da reingeschrieben, um mich auf ihn berufen zu können. Und der andere Fehler war, dass ich den Eindruck erweckt habe, dass die Vorratsdatenspeicherung alle Webseiten, die man aufruft, speichert. Dass die Vorratsdatenspeicherung, wie sie in Kraft war, das getan hätte. Und das war nicht der Fall. Sondern hauptsächlich eben die Konzentration auf Kommunikationsdaten. Das macht es ja nicht minder schlimm, wenn man sich überlegt, dass die Aufenthaltsorte bei Telefonanrufen und Gesprächspartner und das eben auch bei E-Mails bei größeren Providern geschehen sollte, macht es nicht weniger schlimm. Aber quasi die tatsächliche, komplette Browser-History wurde so nicht gespeichert. Wurde ich von AK-Vorratmitgliedern darauf hingewiesen. Ich glaube, in unseren Kommentaren stand auch drin, dass das eine häufige Fehlannahme ist, die dem Protest gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung sicherlich dienlich ist. Aber sachlich nicht richtig.
Ja, wir lassen uns auch gerne verbessern, so ist es nicht. Von daher fühlt euch alle aufgefordert, hier in den Kommentaren dazu beizutragen. Das soll ja hier durchaus auch ein geschlossener Kreislauf sein, mit dem Feedback und dem Angebot, Nachrichten zu verstehen. Jetzt haben wir letztes Mal versucht, überhaupt erstmal eine Grundlage zu legen, dass man sagen kann, da haben wir ja schon mal drüber gesprochen. Da wir bisher noch überhaupt nichts gesprochen haben, muss man ja erstmal überhaupt irgendwas gesprochen haben und haben viele Sachen ausgepackt, die unserer Meinung nach der Erwähnung wert sind. Da gab es natürlich noch eine ganze Menge mehr. Eins, was wir erstmal beiseite gelegt haben, weil es uns den Rahmen der ersten Sendung gesprengt hätte, ist WikiLeaks. Die haben sich jetzt allerdings wieder, oder sind quasi wieder ins Rampenlicht geschoben worden, da es jetzt eine Entscheidung gab, nämlich die Entscheidung, den Julian Assange, der ja seit geraumer Zeit, das ist jetzt schon ein Jahr, noch nicht ganz, auf jeden Fall seit langer, langer Zeit im Hausarrest gehalten wird in Großbritannien, dass der jetzt ausgeliefert werden darf nach Schweden, damit er dort eben sich den Vorwürfen stellt, bezüglich, ich weiß nicht ganz genau, was die offizielle Formulierung der Anklage ist, aber es geht halt um diesen Fall des sexuellen Missbrauchs. Ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, wie die juristische Formulierung ist, die da in Schweden dafür verwendet wird.
Kann ich gleich...
Genau. Aber das gibt uns sozusagen Gelegenheit, diesen ganzen Fall WikiLeaks auch noch mal kurz darzulegen, wie er sich jetzt so entrollt hat. Diese Organisation gibt es ja eigentlich schon lange, aber natürlich durch die spektakulären Aufdeckungen kam auf einmal da etwas ins Rollen, was einfach eine Dimension erreicht hat, die man so vorher noch nicht gesehen hat für das Thema.
Ja, also genau in diesem Urteil vielleicht, um das nochmal genau in den Rahmen zu setzen, steht also ein EU-Haftbefehl für Julian Assange aus, der sich in Schweden zu einer Befragung melden soll. Das heißt, er ist noch nicht mal als Tatverdächtiger gesucht. Es gibt keinen tatsächlichen Vorwurf, sondern erst mal nur zu einer Befragung. Zumindest stellt es sich juristisch so dar. Und der Grund, warum er sich dagegen wehrt oder gewährt hat, ist ja vor allem, dass insgesamt diese ganze Vorwurf sexuelle Belästigungsvorwürfe als eine Schmierkampagne gegen WikiLeaks gesehen werden. Und dass er außerdem in Schweden die Auslieferung an die USA und dort ein Todesurteil befürchtet. Das ist also die kurze Version, warum Julian sich dagegen wehrt. Und das erste Urteil hatten wir schon im Februar. Das hatte also der Belmarsh Magistrates Court ausgesprochen. Und da wurde ja eigentlich schon gesagt, du sollst ausgeliefert werden. Dagegen haben sie Berufungen eingelegt. Und diese Berufungen haben sie folgendermaßen begründet. Man begründet irgendwie seine Berufung. Und dann entscheidet das höhere Gericht, in diesem Fall dann ein High Court, darüber, ob die Gründe der Berufung denen entsprechend werden kann, um das ursprüngliche Urteil aufzuheben. Und die Begründung war also, dass dieser Haftbefehl nicht von einer juristischen Autorität ausgesprochen ist. Also es gibt kein Urteil quasi. Es gibt nur das Anliegen einer Staatsanwältin, die gesagt hat, ich möchte, dass der Assange hierhin kommt und sich dazu hier äußert. Der zweite Punkt war, dass sie sagen, drei der vier Vorwürfe, die also erhoben werden, sind nicht in beiden Ländern kriminell. Das ist also eine Voraussetzung für Auslieferung. Und außerdem treffen sie keine, treffen die Beschreibung des Vorfalls, der da tatsächlich stattgefunden hat, nicht zu. Also erstens, sie sind nicht kriminell. Zweitens, sie treffen nicht auf den Sachfall zu. Da sehen wir jetzt auch die Vorwürfe. Der erste Vorwurf war also Zwang und Nötigung. Da hätte er sich also auf eine Person gelegt und ihre Arme festgehalten. Dann sexuelle Belästigung, 13. August 2010, ohne Kondom gegen den ausdrücklichen Wunsch des Partners. Das heißt, das entspricht dort einer sexuellen Belästigung bzw. auch einem schlimmeren Delikt. Dazu komme ich gleich. Dann die sexuelle Belästigung, 18. Da hätte er also nackt neben einer Person gelegen und seinen erigierten Penis an den Körper dieser Person gedrückt. Und der vierte Vorwurf, Vergewaltigungen am 17.08. Da hätte er mit einer Person geschlafen, könnte sich nicht wehren. Also diese Person hätte sich nicht wehren können. Der Treffer also ganz offensichtlich nicht zu. Ganz kurz, diese fallsexuelle Belästigung. Da ist also so das, was ja alle immer etwas komisch erst fanden, dass gesagt wird, ohne Kondom mit einer Person zu schlafen, die den Wunsch hatte, ein Kondom zu benutzen, dass das sexuelle Belästigung wäre. Da gab es ja anfangs ein bisschen Spott auch darüber. Von einigen Leuten. Da würde ich gleich gerne nochmal drauf eingehen, weil ich dann auf die Begründung des Gerichtsurteils jetzt nochmal eingehen wollte. Aber Begründungspunkt Nummer drei, jetzt bin ich echt ein bisschen durcheinander gekommen. Er ist nicht als Beschuldigter geladen, sondern eben als zu einer Befragung. Das ist irgendwie so ein bisschen komisch. Es gibt ja im Prinzip keinen Vorwurf oder so. Da gibt es halt diesen riesigen EU-Haftbefehl. Julian Assange soll da hinkommen. Er ist quasi nicht als Beschuldigter, sondern nur zu einer Befragung geladen. Und vierte Begründung unter all diesen Umständen, dass der europäische Haftbefehl und die Folgen an Aufwand, die darauf entstanden sind, nicht angemessen sind. Assange hatte ja eine Befragung über eine Videoschaltung angeboten. Wenn sie ihn befragen wollen, hat er gesagt, mach mal gerne, hier machen wir uns das mal billig. Wir können ja über Skype uns unterhalten. Ja. Das waren die Gründe, warum sie gesagt haben, wir möchten gerne dieses Urteil, wir gehen da in Berufung. Und jetzt kommt dieser High Court hin und sagt, na ja, Punkt Nummer eins, der Haftbefehl sei nicht von einer juristischen Autorität. Und sagt der High Court, ja, dieser Haftbefehl, dieser Ermittlerin ist von Richtern geprüft. Ermittler können keine Haftbefehle ausstellen. Sie brauchen einen Richter, der das unterschreibt. Und die Richter eines anderen souveränen Staates müssen respektiert werden. Das heißt also, sagen, das ist von einer juristischen Autorität. Dann wurde gesagt, zweiter Punkt, die Delikte wären nicht in beiden Ländern kriminell. Da haben die Richter gesagt, na ja, eine Einwilligung nur mit Kondom ist gleichbedeutend mit einer Nichteinwilligung ohne Kondom. Also ist es eine sexuelle Belästigung gewesen. Und dieses Delikt ist auch strafbar in Schweden. Also Punkt 2 der Berufungsbegründung trifft nicht zu. Drittens, das war der interessantere Teil, dass man sagte, er wäre nicht als Beschuldigter geladen, sondern eben nur zu einer Befragung. Da sagten die Richter, es kommt das Wort beschuldigt tatsächlich nicht in dem Haftbefehl vor. Das heißt also, der offizielle Haftbefehl lautet irgendwie auf, ich möchte gerne Julian Assange befragen. Aber alles an diesem Fall deutet eindeutig darauf hin, dass er da als Beschuldigter bzw. Tatverdächtigter in diesem Fall verlangt wird. Und es scheint weiterhin eine ausführliche Untersuchung stattgefunden zu haben. Und der Haftbefehl stellt klare Anschuldigungen dar. Es geht nicht irgendwie darum, dass sie ihn aus dem Haftbefehl relativ klar hervorgehen, dass sie ihn nicht einfach nur als Zeugen befragen wollen.
Also er gilt quasi als Verdächtiger in dem Sinne.
Genau, obwohl sie es explizit dann nicht stehen haben. Es gibt ja auch bei polizeilichen Vorladungen den Unterschied, dass du als Zeuge geladen werden kannst oder als Beschuldigter. Und das macht ja durchaus einen Unterschied. Darauf haben sie sich eben in diesem Fall versucht zu beziehen. Das Gericht hat gesagt, das mag sein, dass dann irgendwo beschuldigt steht, aber ist ja wohl offensichtlich. Also auch diesen Fall abgewiesen. Und den vierten Einwand der Angemessenheit haben sie auch gesagt, das ist eine Frage, die muss in Schweden geklärt werden. Und da wurde ja die Berufung abgelehnt. Und dass quasi die Richter in den UK nicht über die Angemessenheit diese Sache mehr zu entscheiden haben, weil der EU-Haftbefehl eben aus Schweden käme. Und der Vorschlag einer Videokonferenz hätte sicher irgendwie gezeigt, dass der unpraktikabel ist und dann ein langer Streit daraus entstehen würde. Und halten sie also auch nicht für angemessen und haben dann gesagt, alles klar. Wir weisen das in allen Punkten ab. Und dann gibt's, was war, glaube ich, die Frist, 14 Tage nachdem das dann rechtsgültig ist, könnte er auch schon im Flieger sitzen, spätestens. Und jetzt war irgendwie klar, sie hätten aber noch die Möglichkeit, das jetzt noch vor den Supreme Court zu bringen. Und haben sich da aber relativ bedeckt gehalten. Da hab ich bei dem Erich Möchel was ganz Interessantes gefunden. Erich Möchel arbeitet beim ORF. Und wie kann man das sagen, außer dass er einfach ein cooler Typ ist? Also was kann man noch mehr über Erich sagen?
Erich ist, sagen wir mal, auch ein Aktivist, auf jeden Fall. Steckt ja auch hinter vielen Bewegungen wie Quintessence zum Beispiel, die den Big Brother Award in Österreich machen. Also ich weiß nicht, wie sein konkretes Engagement derzeit ganz konkret aussieht, aber er ist halt definitiv Teil dieses Kulturraums und hat eben über lange, lange Zeit beim ORF die einzige nennenswerte Netzstimme eigentlich im öffentlichen, sagt man öffentlich-rechtlich auch in Österreich, ich weiß es gerade gar nicht, also in diesem Journalismus-Bereich gemacht. Wie hieß denn verdammt? Das hab ich gerade irgendwie nicht parat.
Weißt du, das mit dem F?
Future Zone, genau. Also Erich hat lange, lange Zeit eigentlich der führende Mitschreiber bei Future Zone bis an die Future Zone eingestellt worden ist. Mittlerweile gibt es ja zumindest ein Archiv von den ganzen Future Zone Beiträgen, aber das war einfach über lange, lange Zeit eine der wichtigsten Quellen und Rechercheorte im Netz. Und ist jetzt immer noch ein gutes Archiv, aber Erich selber ist natürlich immer noch dabei. Und was hat er jetzt geschrieben?
Genau, also Erich hatte dann im ORF-Blog geschrieben, dass über diese Frage der Berufung, dass ist nämlich, dass viele Prozessbeobachter die Sorge, das ist ja eigentlich die Hauptfurcht für alle WikiLeaks- und Julian Assange-Sympathisanten, dass Schweden ihn dann in die USA ausliefern würde. Und wenn die USA dem Mann habhaft werden, dann kann man sich ja ungefähr vorstellen, dass der seine Fußfesselzeit irgendwo in England noch als einen sehr angenehmen Urlaub empfinden wird im Vergleich dazu, wenn die USA ihn dann irgendwie mal in die Finger kriegen sollten. Und viele teilen aber genau diese Sorge nicht und sagen, dass eigentlich, und das war so ein Forbes-Analyst, den Erich da zitiert, in UK die Auslieferung wahrscheinlicher wäre, weil die UK seit 2003 sogar eigene Bürger an die USA ausliefern. Während Schweden darauf beschränkt ist, dass das Delikt, weswegen sie ausweisen oder ausliefern, auch in Schweden strafbar sein muss. Und gleichzeitig es in den USA immer noch gar keine Anklage gibt. Da ist ja auch immer noch eine Grand Jury, die sich überhaupt damit auseinandersetzt, ob man ihn jetzt wegen irgendetwas...
Ob welcher Basis man ihn überhaupt anklagen kann.
Genau. Und entsprechend wird da also die Meinung vertreten, wenn er jetzt nach Schweden gehen würde, dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit relativ gering ist, dass unter den aktuellen Bedingungen, dass er sofort dann irgendwie in die USA weiter ausgewiesen wird. Also es wäre denkbar, dass die USA dann, wenn er einmal in Schweden ist, also könnte halt sein, dass dann die Schweden sagen, alles klar, jetzt behalten wir den weiter hier, weil irgendwie die Vorwürfe nicht geklärt sind. Und dass währenddessen die USA sagen, alles klar, jetzt schnüren wir hier unser Päckchen zusammen. Und dann muss dieses Päckchen auch noch so geschnürt sein, dass es in Schweden genauso strafbar wäre. Und dann wäre es also denkbar. Aber insgesamt wird da also die Meinung vertreten, dass die USA sich unter den jetzigen Bedingungen besser einfach direkt an England wenden könnten, als irgendwie den Umweg über Schweden zu gehen.
Naja, wahrscheinlich, oder was heißt wahrscheinlich, kann auch einfach sein, dass er Angst vor der Verurteilung in Schweden hat. Das ist ja nun auch mal sehr naheliegend. Jetzt gibt es diese, ich weiß nicht, Anklagebeschuldigung, Zeugenbefragung, wie auch immer man das jetzt nennen soll. Und das bedroht natürlich seine Existenz bzw. sein Projekt in demselben Maße.
Absolut, ja.
Wir wissen alle nicht, was da jetzt wirklich vorgefallen ist. Ich hab auch keine Ahnung, wie das bewertet wird. Ich denke allerdings, dass wenn es tatsächlich zu so einer Situation kommen würde, wo er in Schweden erst mal, nachdem sie sich seiner Habhaft gemacht haben, dass sie dann so ein Ding drehen mit, wir finden jetzt mal hier einen juristischen Weg, ihn durch die Hintertür an die USA loszuwerden. Und danach machen wir die Augen zu. Und das interessiert uns nicht mehr. Ich kann nicht behaupten, ein Schwedenexperte zu sein. Aber es ist schon mein Eindruck, dass das ganz schön rappeln würde in Schweden. Also gerade mit dem Hintergrund der Piratenpartei. Und nicht wahr, wie sehr natürlich diese Informationsverbreitung von WikiLeaks etc. irgendwie auch zumindest kulturell, wenn auch nicht direkt sachlich zusammenhängt mit der gesamten Pirate-Bay-Geschichte. Ich kann mir derzeit das nicht vorstellen, ich will es nicht ausschließen, aber ich kann es mir zumindest nicht vorstellen, dass die politische Elite in Schweden so ohne Weiteres überlebt. Das wäre wahrscheinlich für wer auch immer gerade das Heft in der Hand hat, ein wirklich harter Brocken, wo die sich eine Menge Ärger einhandeln könnten, einfach auf Basis von Protesten etc. Aber WikiLeaks ist ja unabhängig von diesem Auslieferungsfall. Das ist ja jetzt quasi nur die News. Jetzt hatten wir noch mal so ein bisschen was zur jüngeren Geschichte sagen. Es gab ja auch diese Problematik, dass er eben unter anderem jetzt wegen dieser Anschuldigung aber auch aus anderen Gründen einfach eine ganze Menge Geld in die Hand nehmen wollte oder meinte zu müssen, um diese Serverinfrastruktur am Laufen zu halten bzw. alles am Laufen zu erhalten. Man gewinnt so den Eindruck, dass es jetzt fast schon mehr um juristische Kosten geht als um Serverkosten, weil auch dieses riesige verflochtene Servernetz, von dem irgendwie immer die Rede war, sich so wahrscheinlich gar nicht jemals manifestiert hat. Das ist zumindest mein Eindruck, dass da einfach sehr viel mehr behauptet wurde, wie ausgebufft diese ganze Infrastruktur sei, aber dass da eigentlich relativ wenig dahinter steht. Und seitdem auch diese schon fast boulevardeske Arie da mit OpenLeaks durchgezogen wurde, auf beiden Seiten, dass eigentlich klar wurde, dass da einfach technisch überhaupt nichts mehr steht. Und ich meine de facto ist WikiLeaks seit gut einem Jahr überhaupt nicht mehr als solches tätig. Also es gibt nicht die Webseite, wo man Dokumente abwerfen kann. Das ist alles so theoretisch. Ja, das gab es mal. Und schon lange ist WikiLeaks dysfunktional. Und ich glaube, vor zwei, drei Wochen wurde auch mehr oder weniger verkündet, dass das jetzt erstmal bleiben wird.
Genau, da haben sie also gesagt, wir machen jetzt gar nichts mehr, weil wir keine Kohle mehr haben. Und der Grund dafür ist ja, weiß ich, das ist ja denke ich auch so ausreichend groß durch die Medien gegangen, dass wir das jetzt nicht mehr im Detail nochmal ansprechen müssen, dass Bank of America, Visa, Mastercard, Paypal und Western Union mehr oder weniger offensichtlich auf freiwilliger Basis oder irgendwelche zumindest keine offiziellen Aufforderungen dazu bekommen haben, die die Wege, die Möglichkeit an WikiLeaks zu spenden eingeschränkt haben. Beziehungsweise hauptsächlich ja sogar an die Wauholland-Stiftung, die es ja dann eigentlich auch betraf, die ja für WikiLeaks eine der Stationen war, dort Spenden entgegenzunehmen und für WikiLeaks zu verwalten. Und jetzt ist also diese Kampagne da am Start und sagt, ja wir können irgendwie nicht weitermachen, wir stellen jetzt alle Aktivitäten ein, könnten aber eigentlich bald ein neues Submission-System, also eine Einreich-Möglichkeit zur Verfügung haben, aber wir haben kein Geld. Das erinnert ein bisschen daran, was sie, welches Jahr war das beim Kongress? Da hat WikiLeaks schon mal runtergefahren. Vor, ist das jetzt zwei oder drei Jahre her? Da gab es den Kongress-Talk von Julien und Daniel, die dann sagten, okay und jetzt machen wir die Bude dicht und warten auf Geld. Das ist jetzt nur schon länger her.
Ich weiß es jetzt nicht mehr ganz genau. Es gab ja auch mehrere Vorträge. Ich guck grad mal. 26, C3.
Also es gab, also die, die, die, die, belassen wir es dabei, bevor ich jetzt wieder einen Fehler mache. Es gab schon einmal etwas, das WikiLeaks quasi gesagt hat, okay, wir müssen uns auf Fundraising konzentrieren. Und das hat damals auch ganz gut funktioniert. Und in dieser Aussage heißt es jetzt, dass ihnen, ist also ein bisschen schwammig immer, dass sie sagen, dass 95 Prozent der Einkünfte durch diese finanzielle Blockade ihnen gesperrt sind oder entgehen. Und das, da ist jetzt mir ein bisschen unklar und ich hab da auch keine wirkliche Antwort drauf gefunden, was jetzt diese 95 Prozent sind. Also heißt das, sie kriegen nur 5 Prozent von dem Geld, was sie eigentlich bräuchten? Oder heißt das, früher haben andere Wege als Bank of America, Visa, Paypal und so weiter 5 Prozent ausgemacht? Und das, was wir jetzt bekommen, ist also 5 Prozent von dem, was die Leute uns wirklich geben wollen. Und deswegen fehlen uns 95. Also es ist irgendwie ein bisschen unklar, wie das zustande kommt. Dann gab es ja dieses schöne Video, das ist aber schon auch etwas älter. Dieses Anti-Mastercard-Video. Der WikiLeaks Twitter-Account beschränkt sich in den letzten Tagen darauf zu betonen, dass man an die arische Aryan Nation spenden kann, aber nicht an WikiLeaks. Und gleichzeitig findet man dann unter shop.wikileaks.org/donatediemöglichkeiten, wie man spenden kann. Und zur allgemeinen großen Überraschung steht da, sie können spenden über Kreditkarte, Paypal, Check, Banktransfer, SMS, Bitcoin und Moneygram. Und sogar irgendwie über Facebook. Das heißt also, ihre finanzielle Blockade scheint jetzt auch nicht mehr so effektiv zu sein. Flatter kann man auch. Dann sind sie sogar noch so freundlich gewesen, haben auch den Bradley Manning Defense Fund mit aufgenommen.
Das heißt, sie weisen darauf hin, dass auch Bradley Manning zu seiner Verteidigung, also Bradley Manning, der Whistleblower, der vermutlich die ganzen Dokumente, die in den letzten Jahren so viel Aufwebens gemacht haben, geliefert haben, einschließlich dieses Videos, mit dem die ganze Sache eigentlich losgetreten wurde von dieses Hubschrauber-Piloten-Video im Irak.
Also sie sagen, man soll auch an Bradley Mannings für seine Verteidigung spenden, aber natürlich auch an den Julian Assange Defense Fund, der nämlich, interessanter Punkt, unabhängig davon ist. Da weiß ich also, es gab also Markus von Netzpolitik, hat dann mal versucht, bei der Vau Holland Stiftung anzufragen, wie denn so im Moment der Spendenstand bei WikiLeaks ist, wie viel Geld sie denn ausgegeben haben. Und es war also so, dass als die juristischen Auseinandersetzungen anfingen, sei es jetzt mit OpenLeaks und diese Schwedengeschichte, da gab es natürlich die Debatte zwischen WikiLeaks und der Vau Holland Stiftung, bzw. Julian und der Vau Holland Stiftung, was also da noch ein zweckbestimmtes Mittel ist und was nicht. Also wofür das Geld, was bei der Vau Holland Stiftung nämlich liegt und an WikiLeaks gegen Rechnungen herausgegeben wird. Also es ist nicht so, als würde die Vau Holland Stiftung da monatlich einfach eine Überweisung an WikiLeaks machen, sondern die...
Also alles nur gegen Beleg?
Genau, alles gegen Beleg.
Das muss sie auch so machen, weil sie ja sagt, wir sind hier zweckgebunden. Und diese Zweckgebundenheit muss natürlich auch nachgewiesen werden. Da kann man nicht jetzt einfach mal die Gelder irgendwo hinschieben, sondern es geht eigentlich nur, wenn WikiLeaks sagt, wir haben die und die Ausgaben, hier ist der Beleg dafür, bitte um Erstattung und dann geht das eben so ab. Das bedeutet vermutlich, dass eben ein Großteil des gespendeten Geldes in dem Sinne gar nicht in den Händen von WikiLeaks ist.
Richtig. Und dann hat Markus die Anfrage gemacht an die Vauholland-Stiftung, hat gesagt, sag doch mal, wie viel liegt denn da im Moment bei euch? Markus Becketal, der Chefredakteur, Gründer von netzpolitik.org. Und da hat die Vauholland-Stiftung erst mal keinen... Also hat sich dann entschieden zu sagen, wir haben unsere normalen Berichte und die erscheinen jährlich. Und wir geben jetzt zwischenzeitlich da keine Auskunft über Spendenstände. Das heißt, da kann man jetzt nichts zu sagen. Wird man dann sehen. Aber es gibt auf jeden Fall den Julian Assange Defense Fund. Und es sieht also danach aus, dass sie das trennen, was ja auch eigentlich eine ganz saubere Sache ist, so etwas zu trennen, wenn er sich dagegen Vorwürfe wehren muss. Dass das natürlich nicht aus WikiLeaks-Mitteln geschehen kann. Was ich so persönlich, wir haben das ja gerade schon angesprochen, dann ging diese Open-Leaks-Debatte da los. Und wir haben seit einem Jahr schauen wir uns da irgendwie diesen Quatsch an. Und mein persönlicher Eindruck ist tatsächlich, was schon auch wirklich ganz zu Beginn der Vorwürfe gegen Julian gesagt wurde, dass er sich den stellen muss. Also es ist einfach, es scheint einfach ein bisschen schmierig. Es sieht einfach ein bisschen unsauber aus, wie er sich jetzt noch versucht gegen diese Auslieferung nach Schweden zu wehren. Und vor allem, wenn dann Stimmen laut werden, die sagen, naja, eigentlich hat er da nicht so viel zu befürchten, dann macht das einfach ein bisschen schlechten Eindruck inzwischen.
Na gut, ich meine, es gibt sicherlich auch Stimmen, die ihm sagen, dass er da eine Menge zu befürchten hat. Von daher ist das natürlich auch eine Frage der persönlichen Abwägung. Aber mittlerweile ist eigentlich die gesamte Außenkommunikation von WikiLeaks meiner Meinung nach eigentlich ein ziemliches Desaster. Man hat da diesen Twitter-Account, der irgendwie die ganze Zeit auf alles Mögliche einzuschlagen versucht und mit Vergleichen daherkommt. Mit hier für Nazis könnt ihr spenden und für WikiLeaks nicht. Da ist natürlich auch was dran. Das ist schon irgendwie gut. Aber die eigentliche Strategie mit wir veröffentlichen hier Sachen ist durch die Ereignisse rund um die letzten Veröffentlichungen vollkommen im Hintergrund getreten. Es gibt eigentlich nur noch diesen großen Krieg mit den USA. Aber das eigentliche Versprechen von WikiLeaks, so ein Zentrum zu sein, was einfach auch überhaupt veröffentlicht, das tritt extrem im Hintergrund. Weil WikiLeaks veröffentlicht kaum noch irgendetwas. Und auch das, was sie haben, diese ganzen Dokumente, die Bradley Manning dort abgeliefert hat, also mutmaßlich Bradley Manning dort abgeliefert hat. Insbesondere eben diese Cables, das Cablegate, also die Mitschnitte der Diplomatenkommunikation der USA. Diese Protokolle, die geheim waren. Die sind ja dann auch noch durch diese vollkommen bekloppte Aktion auch noch veröffentlicht worden, das muss man sich mal vorstellen. Also der Strategiewechsel nach der ersten Veröffentlichung mit diesem College-of-Damage-Video, was ihnen auch eine Menge Kritik eingebracht hat, weil sie ja nicht nur das Dokument als solches veröffentlicht haben, sondern ein Team von WikiLeaks-Unterstützern, die sich eben bemüht haben, dieses Video aufzubereiten, was sicherlich vertretbar ist. Ich hab ja im Chaos-Radio Express mit Rob Kronkreib, der dabei war, er hat sich ja auch zu geäußert. Das ist einfach, wenn man es nicht auch aufbereitet, dann wird es auch nicht verstanden. Ich verstehe da beide Seiten, wie sie ja rangegangen sind. Tatsache ist, dass es in der Außenkommunikation schwierig wurde, weil eben diese klare Trennung mit wir sind ein neutraler Veröffentlicher und wir bewerten diese Dokumente nicht, versus wir sind jetzt aber eigentlich mal total gegen Krieg und sind jetzt hier irgendwie Teil des Widerstands. Das war dadurch natürlich irgendwie zumindest, wenn nicht aufgehoben, aber infrage gestellt. Und das ging bei diesen Cable Gates dann auch nicht weiter. Man hat sich dann eben so darauf eingelassen, es professioneller zu machen, anführungsstrichen, effektiver zu machen. Das heißt, die Cables waren alle da. Man hatte da diese 100 Prozent, dann hat man eben exklusive Medienpartner gehabt, die vorher sich alle ein bisschen angepisst fühlten, weil sie nicht mitspielen durften und dann auch dementsprechend schlechte Presse gemacht haben. Ich weiß nicht, inwieweit das noch ausschlaggebend war. Spiegel, Guardian, wer war noch mit dabei? Ich krieg's jetzt gerade nicht zusammen. Zwei oder drei waren's. Oder waren's vier? Ich weiß nicht. Auf jeden Fall ausgewählte Postillen, unter anderem Guardian. Und es lief dann halt tatsächlich so, dass die die gesamten Daten bekommen haben. Und das selber gesichtet haben. Und dann erst mal selber zu einem Stichtag eine gewisse Auswahl getroffen haben, was international als auch national für sie relevant genug erschien.
Am Spiegel war's dann das...
Diese FDP-Geschichte.
Wer doof ist, das denken die USA und unsere Politiker. Guardian hatte sich dann, glaub ich, ein bisschen brisanter Sachen ausgewählt.
Genau, so. Kann ja auch verstehen. Und hätte man dann irgendwie Schlag auf Schlag das gemacht und vielleicht auch irgendwann alles veröffentlicht. Aber da steckt natürlich dann auch gleich wieder diese Journalistendebate dahinter, die natürlich auch gefragt werden muss, wie ist denn das jetzt mit der Gefährdung von Personen? Weil natürlich sind in diesen Dokumenten dann Namen genannt. Wer hat allen welche Informationen geliefert? Ja, in einer gewissen Vertraulichkeit. Ob das eine kriminelle Vertraulichkeit ist oder irgendwie einfach nur eine Quellenvertraulichkeit, sei mal dahingestellt. Und der sogenannte gute Journalismus möchte natürlich jetzt da Quellenschutz betreiben und verhindern, dass Leute da in Mitleidenschaft gezogen werden, die einfach nur die Überbringer der schlechten Nachricht sind.
Da gibt es ja den einen Unterschied. Ist das ein USA-Informant oder ist es ein WikiLeaks-Informant? Ich will das nur deswegen nochmal kurz klarstellen, weil als diese Veröffentlichung der Cables war, stand ja die große Debatte immer an, ja, jetzt sind Informanten gefährdet. Und es war aber nicht ganz klar, welche Informanten. WikiLeaks-Informanten ja nicht unbedingt. Ob es jetzt Bradley Manning diese Sachen da hingeliefert hat oder nicht, ändert sich der Verdacht daran, kann sich wenig daran ändern, ob jetzt diese Cables redigiert sind oder nicht, wenn sie veröffentlicht werden. Aber natürlich für Personen, die mit US-Behörden kollaboriert haben, besteht dann da eventuell die Gefahr, dass irgendjemand das liest und ihren Namen...
Also es gibt da auf jeden Fall eine gewisse Schutzbedürftigkeit, die muss irgendwie beantwortet werden. Und die Antwort, die sie an dem Moment gefunden haben, war, naja, wir machen das jetzt mit den Journalisten. Die wissen schon, wie das geht. Und es wird quasi für einen gelesen. Das ist wieder so bei der Interpretation. Wir wissen, dass in den Cables folgendes drinsteht. Und einzelne Cables kommen dann vielleicht eben auch so wie sie waren oder vielleicht leicht geschwärzt in die Öffentlichkeit. Kann man natürlich auch darüber diskutieren. Ist das das eigentliche Ziel gewesen oder nicht? Unabhängig davon kam es ja dann so weit, dass klar wurde, wie dieses Cable den Weg zum Guardian gefunden hat. Nämlich in dem Julian Assange, vermutlich war er es selber, einfach einen SIP mit all diesen Cables auf den Webserver gepackt hat. Zwar verschlüsselt. Und so landet die Datei dann auch bei diesem Journalisten, der dann wohl in der Lage, ich weiß nicht, war er nicht in der Lage, das zu entschlüsseln, oder war er nicht in der Lage, das zu entpacken? Auf jeden Fall konnte er irgendwie mit der Datei nichts anderes sagen.
Sie war gpg-verschlüsselt und er musste sich dann erklären lassen, wie man mit gpg symmetrisch verschlüsselte Dateien entschlüsselt. Und dann gab es eben dieses Passwort.
Asymmetrisch?
Nee, sie war symmetrisch, deswegen war ja ein Passwort dran. Wenn sie asymmetrisch, dann hätte es ja sein... Das war ja noch der... Also sie war quasi klassisch verschlüsselt. Deswegen gab es dann diese Passwort-Übermittlung. Und dann ist dieser Journalist irgendwann hingegangen, als die Phase war, die ging ja vor wie vielen Monaten, als dann alle anfingen, ihre WikiLeaks-Bücher zu schreiben. Weil ja offensichtlich einige Journalisten, die mit WikiLeaks gearbeitet hatten, auch dachten, da müssen wir jetzt auch irgendwie zeigen, wie toll wir waren. Und dann hatte eben dieser Guardian-Journalist dieses Passwort als Titel für einen Kapitel gegeben. Gleichzeitig war nach mehreren Aufrufen, WikiLeaks-Server-Inhalte zu spiegeln, diese verschlüsselte Datei inzwischen in der freien Wildbahn gelandet.
Weil er sie halt nicht gelöscht hat und die Teil des Backups war. Also da fragt man sich auch wirklich, wie weit es eigentlich mit der technischen Kompetenz manchmal so bestellt ist. Das kann auch einfach für dich nur ein Unfall gewesen sein, aber das darf an der Stelle natürlich nicht passieren.
Darf nicht passieren, aber ich würde trotzdem sagen, dass es relativ eindeutiger Fall ist, dass der Journalist unter keinen Umständen dieses Passwort hätte jemals veröffentlichen dürfen. Also ich finde...
Ja, natürlich nicht, aber man hätte auch diese Datei natürlich nicht stehen lassen, sondern gerade wenn man weiß, dass die einzige Sicherheit dieser Datei ein Passwort ist, was weitergegeben werden kann. Und dann spiegelt man diese Datei nicht, die ja nicht dafür gedacht war, in die Welt zu gehen, sondern die dazu gedacht war, einer einzigen Person zugestellt zu werden. Und das ist das, was ich nicht verstehe. Und ich verstehe auch nicht... Ich meine, danach soll es ja auch noch zu einem Treffen gekommen sein, weil er nicht in der Lage war, die Datei zu machen. Und dann ging es irgendwie über den USB-Stick. Ich meine, das hätte man auch gleich über den toten Briefkasten lösen können. An der Stelle war Convenience wohl der Verführer. Naja, also ich muss sagen, diese ganze WikiLeaks-Geschichte ist mittlerweile, naja, albern ist vielleicht nicht das richtige Wort, aber man möchte sich die Haare raufen, weil es einfach auch Kollateralschäden ganz anderer Art mit sich bringt. Die ganze Debatte des Internetwiderstands hat sich also maßlos militarisiert mit Anonymous, die dann natürlich parteiergreifend für WikiLeaks dann auch anfangen, wieder DDoS-Attacken zu machen, wo, sagen wir mal, dem gestandenen Hacker sich eh der Bauch kräuselt, weil das einfach mal nicht, zumindest jetzt in unserer deutschen Kultur, nicht unbedingt jetzt die empfohlene Methode ist. Das ist einfach auch sehr unklug, weil das natürlich Gegengewalt erzeugt und an der Stelle auch, glaube ich, die einseitige Meinungseinnahme da mindestens schwierig ist in dieser Situation. Also das ist etwas, was man auf jeden Fall weiterverfolgen muss, wie es weitergeht. Haben wir denn noch einen wichtigen Hintergrund vergessen?
Ich wollte nur noch zwei Anmerkungen machen. Einmal, was du gerade schon ansprachst, dass sie sich von diesem Wir-sind-reine-Quellen-Veröffentlichungsplattform ein bisschen entfernt haben und man muss natürlich auch überlegen, dass es natürlich ein Unterschied ist, ob ich so ein Hubschrauber-Video mit einem Vorfall veröffentliche und ob ich jetzt sage, ich mache hier das Mega-Leak und haue das alles raus. Da denke ich, hat man sich von der ursprünglichen Idee des Whistle-Blowings, also einen Missstand aufzeigen, auch ein bisschen entfernt. Natürlich kann man sagen, diese Riesenanzahl, Viertelmillionen Daten sind der Missstand, aber letztendlich wird ja dann doch eher aus einzelnen Cables zitiert, wenn da Missstände aufgezeigt werden. Insofern wäre es vielleicht auch als Veröffentlichungstaktik schlau gewesen, das wirklich Cable-by-Cable zu machen. Ich denke schon, dass man das bemerken muss, dass man anmerken muss, ob man es jetzt gut oder schlecht findet, dass es ein Unterschied ist, ob ich sage, ich bin eine Whistle-Bower-Webseite oder ob ich eine Seite bin, die sagt, okay, wir hauen jetzt hier einen riesen Datensatz, den wir selber nicht überblicken können, einfach an die Sonne. Das ist einfach nochmal ein Unterschied, der dadurch natürlich auch nochmal in anderer Hinsicht angreifbar macht.
Jetzt sind die Daten auf jeden Fall draußen. Ich hatte jetzt noch nicht so den Eindruck, dass die allgemeine Verfügbarkeit aller Cables zu weiteren nennenswerten Umstürzen geführt hat. Ich finde es immer wieder interessant, dass so in bestimmte Hintergründe von irgendwas berichtet werden. Was weiß ich jetzt? Gerade Saudi-Arabien, der Bruder von dem König, der 30 Jahre lang Verteidigungsminister war, ist jetzt gestorben. Wäre der direkte Nachfolger des Königs gewesen. Von daher natürlich nochmal eine extra Meldung. Jetzt kommt irgendein anderer Bruder da in seine Nachfolge. Dann hab ich auch so Artikel gelesen. Wie man einem WikiLeaks-Cable so hat entnehmen können, hatte er da und da schon mal Kontakte oder wurde da erwähnt und so und so eingeschätzt etc. Es ist so eine Background-Noise-Geschichte geworden. Was an sich durchaus positiv ist, weil das ist auch mal wirklich eine Quelle, die man versteht. Da weiß man so, das ist so eine belegte Kommunikation aus dem Hintergrund der internationalen Diplomatenarbeit der USA. Und ich denke auch, dass diese Cables ein ganz interessantes Lernmaterial darstellen, falls sich mal jemand wirklich mit Diplomatie als solcher auseinandersetzen möchte. Ich habe jetzt noch keine Zeit damit verbracht, mir diese Cables durchzulesen. Aber ich habe jetzt auch nicht so den Eindruck, dass wirklich so ein massives Crowdsourcing dort stattfindet. Zumal Anonymous da vorher noch, bevor die alle veröffentlicht wurden, dazu aufgerufen haben. Und dass jetzt wirklich nennenswert noch weitere Skandale haben, heraus destilliert werden können. Vielleicht findet das noch statt, ich weiß nicht. Vielleicht ist das jetzt auch nur selektive Wahrnehmung.
Also man hätte über diese Veröffentlichungsstrategie sich auf jeden Fall irgendwie Gedanken machen sollen können müssen. Wie auch immer. Also die großen Skandale. Also es ist verpufft irgendwie, es scheint irgendwie alles zu verpuffen vor diesem Megaleak. Also ich fürchte, mein Eindruck ist irgendwie, dass selbst wenn da jetzt noch jemand Skandale drin findet, dass das dann immer nur noch einer von den vielen ist. Und deshalb irgendwie nicht so wahrgenommen wird. Oder man irgendwie sagt, aber da gibt es doch noch ganz andere.
Ach, schon wieder ein Cable.
Schon wieder ein Cable-Skandal. Aber die Cables, die sind doch schon ein halbes Jahr alt. Das interessiert mich doch nicht mehr. Also das ist mein subjektiver Eindruck davon, warum eventuell solche Cable-Skandale jetzt in diesem Fall nicht zünden, was sie eventuell gemacht hätten, wenn WikiLeaks tatsächlich durchgegangen wäre und gesagt hätte, ok, jetzt hier, ah, Skandal-Cable gefunden, raus damit, Skandal-Cable gefunden, raus damit. Also es ist ja auch nicht wirklich einfach zu sagen, was da jetzt wirklich die richtige Strategie ist, mit sowas umzugehen.
Linus, wir haben jetzt unsere halbe Stunde auf jeden Fall schon voll. Und ich finde, wir sollten es auch nicht übertreiben. Aber vielleicht grafen wir nochmal kurz das zweite Thema auf, was wir noch auf der Liste hatten, um das zumindest mal beleuchtet zu haben.
Schultrojaner.
Der sogenannte.
Genau, der ja nicht wirklich ein Schultrojaner ist. Aber fangen wir dann vielleicht einfach ganz kurz von vorne an. Seit 2008 ist mit dem zweiten Korb der Urheberrechtsreform, das Kopieren aus Schulbüchern verboten. Davor gab es irgendwie so eine Pauschalvergütungsregelung an die VG Wort, die das dann wiederum an die Urheber und Verlage verteilt hat. Und im zweiten Korb schieß es dann lopidar die Vervielfältigung eines Werkes, das für den Unterrichtsgebrauch an Schulen bestimmt ist, ist stets nur mit Einwilligungen der Berechtigten zulässig. Und Berechtigte sind eben die Verlage.
Die sagen erstmal nein.
Und die sagen dann erstmal nein. Und diese Gesetzesänderung hatte dann schon zur Folge, dass die VG Wort ihren Verteilungsschlüssel auch geändert hat, nämlich mehr an die Verlage zu geben und weniger bis gar nichts an die Urheber, weil ja die Verlage die Berechtigten sind. Und gleichzeitig waren dann die Verlage in der Position, den Kultusministern der Länder die Bedingungen zu diktieren, wie jetzt noch das Kopieren von Schulbüchern oder Unterrichtsmaterialien geregelt werden soll. Weil offizieller Gesetzespunkt war ja einfach, ist nur möglich, wenn wir das genehmigen. Das war quasi der Ausgangspunkt für Verhandlungen mit jetzt den Ländern. Da waren die Verlage also in einer sehr komfortablen Situation und konnten den Kultusministern da, wie gesagt, ganz gut etwas diktieren. Und da haben sie jetzt einen Gesamtvertrag zur Einräumung und Vergütung von Ansprüchen nach § 53 Urhebergesetz beschlossen im Dezember 2010. Der ist auch schon seit Januar in Kraft. Das heißt, das was Markus, wieder Markus Becke, da in Netzpolitik, ist da irgendwie drangeraten, hat eine E-Mail bekommen von jemandem, der irgendwie über dieses Dokument gestolpert ist und sagt immer, was ist denn da los, hast du da schon mal was von gehört? Markus hat sich dann irgendwie umgehört in seinen Bereichen oder mit seinen Kollegen und sagt immer, hast du da schon mal was von gehört? Irgendwie ist das ganze Ding so schön unter dem Radar längst in Kraft. Da haben wir halt in § 6 Absatz 4 den schönen Satz. Die Verlage stellen den Schulaufwands-Trägern sowie den kommunalen und privaten Schulträgern auf eigene Kosten. Eine Plagiatssoftware zur Verfügung, mit welcher digitale Kopien von für den Unterrichtsgebrauch an Schulen bestimmten Werken auf Speichersystemen identifiziert werden können. Die Länder wirken die technische und datenschutzrechtliche Unbedenklichkeit der Software vorausgesetzt darauf hin, dass jährlich mindestens 1% der öffentlichen Schulen ihre Speichersysteme durch Einsatz dieser Plagiatssoftware auf das Vorhandensein solcher Digitalisate prüfen lässt. Also 1% der öffentlichen Schulen sollen ein Programm auf ihren Rechnern installiert haben, welches letztendlich nur eines machen kann, nämlich die gesamte Festplatte durchsuchen nach irgendwelchen Dokumenten, Werken, Ausschnitten, die die Urheberrechte der Schulbuchverlage verletzen.
Also das ist wirklich ein starkes Stück. Also ich finde ja hier schon die Sprache wirklich bemerkenswert. Plagiats, also eins muss man vorwärts stellen. Der Name Schultrojaner, der hat sich ganz schnell entwickelt, als das gemeldet wurde, aber das ist jetzt substanzlos. Es geht nicht darum, dass hier eine Software eingeschleust wird, von der man nichts weiß, die dann auf dem Rechner aktiv wird, sich quasi das Pferd öffnet und alle kommen rausgelaufen. Das ist es nicht, sondern es ist jetzt einfach so ein Buzzword, was wir wahrscheinlich auch so schnell wieder nicht wegkriegen, weil es gerade so schön war. Schultrojaner kommt ja super. Wir werden alle überwacht und alle sind wieder in Panik. Trotz alledem, Plagiate an der Stelle ist auch genauso ein Buzzword, weil es sich ja hier nicht in einem Bildungssinne handelt. Es ist ja nicht, dass da Werke geschrieben werden. Es gibt ja Plagiatssoftware. Es gibt Software, der gibt man einen Text und sie versucht, Quellen zu finden und das abzugleichen. Nur hier geht es ja überhaupt nicht darum, sondern hier geht es schon um Schnüffelsoftware. Einfach einen Scanner, würde ich mal eher sagen, einen Copyright-Scanner, der einfach schaut. Das ist hier ein Dokument, was ich kenne, die wahrscheinlich wie ein Virenscanner arbeitet mit irgendwelchen Hash-Values oder so, die wahrscheinlich auch ausreichend simpel gestrickt ist, um auch genug Fehlverhalten einen Tag zu legen, Vols positives zu haben, oder was weiß ich, was da nicht noch alles bei rauskommen kann.
Wirklich, wirklich frech.
Und der Gedanke, dass wir unsere eigenen Schulen damit kastrieren und quasi die Lehrer auch unter so einem Verfolgungsdruck setzen. Also es ist wirklich...
Es geht noch weiter. Du sagst gerade, die Lehrer unter den Druck setzen. Weiter geht's in Absatz 7. Die Länder verpflichten sich, bei Bekanntwerden von Verstößen gegen die in diesem Gesamtvertrag festgelegten Vorgaben für das Vervielfältigen von urheberrechtlich geschützten Werken gegen die betreffenden staatlichen Schulleiter und Lehrkräfte disziplinarische Maßnahmen einzuleiten. Zivil- und strafrechtliche Ansprüche der Rechteinhaber bleiben unberührt. Das heißt also, die Schule ist verpflichtet, Disziplinarmaßnahmen gegen ihre Lehrer einzureichen. Der Lehrer hat, glaube ich, noch sehr viel mehr Sorge vor einer Disziplinarmaßnahme als jetzt irgendwie vor dieser Software. Vielleicht noch zu dieser Software grundsätzlich. Also natürlich technische und datenschutzrechtliche Unbedenklichkeit. Das steht ja da drin. Jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, wie will man so etwas machen, dass es technisch und datenschutzrechtlich unberührt ist? Es kann ja nur gegen dieses, was wir haben, das Grundrecht auf Vertraulichkeit und Integrität eigen genutzter informationstechnischer System. Dafür muss mir das Gerät nicht gehören. Es geht ja irgendwie darum, dass das dann Schulrechner sind. Wenn man sich jetzt überlegt, dass auf diesen Rechnern, wenn es dann ein Schulrechner ist, kann man davon ausgehen, dass da schülerbezogene Daten drauf sind. Notenvergabe oder so. Das machen Lehrer inzwischen ja auch mit Excel.
Private Kommunikation.
Ja, private Kommunikation. Da gab es diesen Herrn Bornhorn vom Verband der Schulbuchverlage, der sagte, dass Lehrerinnen und Lehrer an ihren Arbeitsplätzen auch private E-Mails abriefen. Hält er also für ausgeschlossen. Und verweist im Übrigen auf die Länder, die dafür zuständig seien, zu kontrollieren, dass Datenschutzrechte gewahrt blieben. Das heißt also auch wieder so diese Idee, naja, die Datenschutzer werden uns ja irgendwie, werden ja dafür sorgen, dass das alles in Ordnung ist. Dann hatte sich dann der Bildungsminister Eckhard Klug dazu geäußert mit den Worten, dass wir viel lernen um nichts. Selbstverständlich lassen wir nichts an die Schulen, was die Unbedenklichkeitsbescheinigung nicht erhält. Und hier wird etwas als Schultrojaner diffamiert, was es noch gar nicht gibt. Ja, das habe ich jetzt aus einem Taz-Artikel. Das ist wahrscheinlich, wenn ich mich nicht täusche, war das NRW oder so. Aber das musst du noch mal ganz kurz nachschauen, wenn du das hinkriegst. Ich würde noch mal ganz gerne darauf eingehen, weil im Rahmen der Recherche bin ich auf die Kopierbroschüre.
Schleswig-Holstein im Müringen. Eckhard Klug, FDP. Minister für Bildung und Kultur Schleswig-Holstein.
Der ist es. Jetzt gibt es diese Kopierbroschüre. Die war wunderschön. Die kannte ich auch noch nicht. Da gibt es eine Kopierbroschüre für die Lehrer. Es gibt neue Regeln für das Fotokopieren von Schulen. Wie lauten die neuen Regeln? Und dann mit Fallbeispielen, was sie dürfen. Schön ist, in dieser Broschüre steht drin, wichtig ist, die kopieren dürfen Schulbücher und sonstige Unterrichtsmaterialien nicht ersetzen. Die Lehrkräfte sollen Kopien aber in einem sinnvollen Umfang nutzen dürfen. Sie haben eigentlich nur Einschränkungen bekommen. Dann gibt es diese schöne Broschüre, in der dann steht, die Lehrkräfte profitieren von dem neuen Fotokopiervertrag in zweifacher Hinsicht. Die Regelungen sind für den Unterrichtsalltag praktikabel und Lehrerinnen und Lehrer erhalten Rechtssicherheit. Rechtssicherheit heißt in dem Fall mit Sicherheit. Sie dürfen bis zu 12% eines jeden Werkes maximal jedoch 20 Seiten kopieren. Das gilt wirklich für alle Werke. Das heißt auch Schulbücher, Arbeitshefte, Sach- und Musikbücher. Und ganze Werke darf man kleinere Musikeditionen von maximal sechs Seiten. Also gibt es völlig utopische Regeln. Also darf ich ein Bild aus einem Schulbuch kopieren und an die Schüler verteilen? Antwort Ja. Darf ich machen. Darf ich ein Bild aus einem Schulbuch einscannen in ein eigenes Arbeitsblatt integrieren und dieses Arbeitsblatt dann für meine Schüler vervielfältigen? Antwort Nein. Durch das Einscannen entsteht eine digitale Kopie. Eine solche Kopie aus Urheberunterrichtswerken ist nicht zulässig. Sie verbieten die digitale Kopie. Kann ich die Tabelle muslimische Bevölkerung in Europa aus einem Schulbuch einscannen und meinen Schülern via Laptop und Beamer zeigen? Kann ich etwas aus einem Buch scannen und projizieren, was schon immer bei Lehrern früher schon gemacht wurde mit der Kopie auf Folie? Nein, durch das Einscannen entsteht eine digitale Kopie. Eine digitale Kopie aus Unterrichtswerken für den Unterrichtsgebrauch ist nicht gestattet. Sie dürfen keine digitalen Kopien machen. Und das schon irgendwie seit einer Entscheidung von 2008 und einer Broschüre von 2009.
Und das nennen sie dann Digitalisate.
Das sind Digitalisate, ja.
Hast du das schon mal vorher gehört?
Nee.
Also das ist ja wirklich...
Gibt es aber offensichtlich seit 2008.
Wir wollen ja hier neutral bleiben. Ich sag mal, das ist doch eine sehr zweifelhafte Vorgehensweise.
Es zeigt sich... Also es ist halt sowas von weltfremd, ja. Wenn man sich das überlegt, wie funktioniert so ein Schulalltag und was wollen die da überhaupt machen. Das Einzige und darauf, wie es Ilya Braun auf dem Blog der Linken hin ist, dass es eindeutig sagt, dass das zutrifft für den Unterrichtsgebrauch... Moment, wie war es wörtlich? Für den Unterrichtsgebrauch gedachten Werken. Das heißt, sie können sich jetzt eigentlich bei anderen Dingen bedienen. Und da gilt das nicht. Das heißt, wenn die Lehrer jetzt darauf... Also die Vervielfältigung eines Werkes, das für den Unterrichtsgebrauch an Schulen bestimmt ist, ist stets nur mit Einwilligung des Berechtigten zulässig. Jetzt könnte man natürlich sagen, wir konzentrieren uns dann auf Werke, die nicht dafür bestimmt sind. Das heißt also ein Zeitungsartikel oder ein Wikipedia-Beitrag oder so dürfen Lehrer dann weiterhin in ihrem Unterricht nutzen.
Ja, also das ist natürlich wieder so ein ganz klassischer Fall. Und es ist eigentlich sehr unangenehm zu sehen, dass jetzt auch noch Schulbuchverlage oder gerade Schulbuchverlage an der Stelle wirklich so hart auf die Keule hauen. Weil hier trifft es einfach mal einfach auch mal vollständig die Falschen. Weil ich meine, wenn irgendwo eine flexible Auslegung dieser ganzen Urheberrechtsproblematik dringendst erforderlich ist, dann doch wohl im Bildungsbereich und Lehrern zu unterstellen, die jetzt sich bemühen, ihren Schülern was beizubringen, dass sie einfach die ganze Zeit dort eine Copyright-Violation-Maschine darstellen. Dass sie das irgendwie die ganze Zeit in demselben Bewusstsein machen, als würden sie sich die ganze Zeit aus dem Schulnetz die Beatles runterladen, illegal. Das ist einfach eine Frechheit. Das ist wirklich unfassbar. Ich frage mich, was der politische Widerstand ist. Ich meine, wenn das jetzt quasi im Gesetz steht, was heißt das?
Es ist ein Vertrag zwischen denen, den die Bundesländer mit diesen... Vertrag, okay. Ja, die mit diesen Interessenvertretern, Rechteinhabern, so geschlossen haben. Jetzt sagte Sabine Leuthäuser-Schnarrenbärer, Justizministerin, sagte, dass sie das als den Ärger der Woche bezeichnet. Und dass das selbstverständlich wegmüsse. Jetzt werden wir sehen, ob sie das hinkriegt. Was wir da insgesamt für eine Tendenz feststellen, ist ja wirklich, dass der Staat eines seiner wichtigsten Aufgaben, nämlich für Bildung zu sorgen, da wirklich unter diese Idee des geistigen Eigentums, Vervielfältigungsrechte und so weiter, dahinter noch zurückstellt. Und dass sich in so einer ganz Offensichtlichkeit in so eine Gefahr begibt, also ich finde dieser Schultrojaner okay geschenkt, sollten sie eigentlich niemals in die Reihe kriegen, so etwas vernünftig zu machen. Also wenn wir irgendwo noch einen Datenschutzbeauftragten haben, der seine Arbeit halbwegs ernst nimmt, dann werden sie den Zweifelsfall nie installieren können. Zweitens selbst wenn es einen gäbe, wäre das ungefähr das schlecht gehütigste Geheimnis an dieser Schule, sodass irgendwann klar wäre, auf welchem Rechner der nicht ist, oder auf welchem Privatrechner er eben nicht ist. Und die Schule müsste dann, ja im Prinzip könnte die aufhören, weiter Computer zu kaufen, weil sie irgendwie mit ihrem, weil die Geräte eh keiner mehr nutzen kann, weil sie infiziert sind, so ungefähr. Also insofern trifft dann da dieser Begriff Trojaner, auch wenn er sachlich total falsch ist, natürlich irgendwie so ein bisschen auch den Punkt, was diese Software dann letztendlich für diesen Rechner bedeutet. Ähm, ansonsten bin ich ja sowieso gerade im Bildungsbereich, ja, also gerade im Bildungsbereich, denke ich, muss man sich ganz groß und stark für diese Fair-Use-Klauseln aussprechen und sich überlegen, weil, also wenn wir da jetzt noch das Urheberrecht irgendwie so massiv durchsetzen und irgendwie sogar so weit gehen, dass die Länder sich freiwillig verpflichten, ihre Angestellten irgendwie mit Schnüffel-Software oder Kontrollsoftware, Urheberrechtsscannern zu überwachen und dann auch noch sagen, wir machen das auch noch, wir nehmen das als Disziplinarmaßnahme auf. Also wäre mir jetzt auch nicht bekannt, wahrscheinlich gab es dafür früher auch schon irgendwie eine Rechtsgrundlage, dass theoretisch ein Lehrer, der sich da, der großartig dagegen...
Der eine Folie anzeigt.
Dass da theoretisch das auch natürlich irgendwie disziplinarrechtlich Konsequenzen haben hätte können. Und eventuell gab es auch vielleicht irgendwann mal jemanden, der seinen Schülern eine CD gebrannt hat und dann vielleicht auch einen Eintrag in die Personalakte bekommen hat.
Durch diese technische Überwachbarkeit und diese Automatisierung entsteht natürlich ein ganz neues Bedrohungspotenzial, wo es vorher sich real nicht hat durchschlagen können, auch wenn die Gesetzgebung an sich schon bekloppt war, wir jetzt an so einen Punkt kommen, wo man eben auch einsehen muss, dass hier sich gesetzlich doch was bewegen muss. Weil ich will da nicht Lehrer sein mit irgendwie so einem Damoklass-Schwer die ganze Zeit.
Du willst da vor allem nicht Schüler sein. Was kriegst du denn da noch für Unterrichtsmaterial? Dann musst du dich entweder, musst du dann jedes Schuljahr da eine Berserker-Summe für irgendwelche Schulbücher ausgeben oder du kriegst eben schlechtes Unterrichtsmaterial. Weil das ist ja genau das, was dann passiert. Dann werden die Bücher eben noch ein Jahr gemacht. Dann müssen die noch ein Jahr gehalten werden. Und dann muss der Lehrer eben versuchen, irgendwo andersherr seine Sachen zu bekommen. Also gerade Schulbildung, also Sorry, ist ja wirklich auch seit vielen Jahren eher ein unverändertes Feld. Grundrechte Arten haben sich da wenig geändert und kommen wenig Neues dazu. Und das sind irgendwie sehr, sehr komische Verhältnisse, die da entstehen.
Im Prinzip wäre es durchaus vorstellbar, das ist vielleicht auch mal eine Bedrohung, die vielleicht die Schulverlage auch mal begreifen müssen oder vielleicht eine Chance, die sie auch für sich selber sehen müssen, dass sie sich da auch frühzeitig drauf einstellen, wie du schon sagst. Das meiste, was man so in der Schule lernt, von dem wir wissen, dass wir es Kindern beibringen wollen, wäre durchaus Wikipedia-Style zu erarbeiten. Es gibt ja auch entsprechende Initiativen so in der Wikipedia-Welt. Ich habe nicht den Eindruck, dass das schon so die Dynamik hat, die es vielleicht verdient hätte. Ich kann mir aber sehr gut vorstellen, dass gerade durch solche Ereignisse da etwas Beschleunigung mit reinkommt. Man stelle sich nur vor, es würde wirklich so das universelle, grundrechten Mathematik-Schulbuch geschrieben werden. Durch so eine kollektive Spende, wo Leute sagen, ich mache mir mal dieses Kapitel und tausend Leute lesen das gegen, etc. Das ist ja durchaus vorstellbar. Da gibt es im Detail immer Probleme, wie auch bei der Wikipedia-Probleme. Aber dass das jetzt unmöglich wäre, ist uns klar. Es ist nicht unmöglich. Es ist in gewisser Hinsicht sehr wahrscheinlich, dass es früher oder später stattfinden wird. Wenn man jetzt Bildungsminister ist, sollte das vielleicht sogar glatt mal eine Idee sein, dass man so etwas einfach mal herannimmt. Dass man sich diese ganzen Verlage, vielleicht eher die Autoren, schnappt und sagt, so hier, macht mal was. Verlage denkt euch mal ein Business-Modell aus, wie ihr den Schulen eine Dienstleistung bieten könnt, die relevant ist, die aber das Grundlegende jetzt nicht immer wieder in einer neuen Auflage macht, weil sich drei Worte geändert haben. Und dann mit so einem Copyright-Terror auch noch alle nerven, dass man das nicht kopieren darf, weil es geht einfach nicht. Ich denke, da ist noch Luft.
Andererseits hätten sich die Verlage ja auch mal überlegen können. Die kriegen ja sowieso alles irgendwie so gut wie pauschal vergütet da. Warum sie nicht ihre Kopierkosten senken wollen und sagen, okay, da machen wir jetzt online Lehrmittel und streichen jährlich einen gewissen Betrag an Nutzungsrechten ein von den Schulen oder von den Ländern und stellen unseren Kram nur noch online zur Verfügung oder nur noch in digitalisierter Form und lassen uns ja pauschale Abgaben geben. Weil wenn sie auffallen müssten, diese ganzen Bücher immer zu drucken, da wird ja dann wirklich eine Marge entstehen. Also es ist irgendwie völlig unbegreiflich, was die sich irgendwie davon verhoffen, eben diesem Papier auch verhaftet zu bleiben. Zu sagen, wir wollen Bücher verkaufen und ihr dürft die nicht digital kopieren. Wir wollen sie auch selber mal irgendwann aus dieser Nummer wieder rauskommen.
Passt alles nicht.
Ganz, ganz komische Sache.
Wir müssen uns jetzt auch überlegen, wie wir hier aus unserer Nummer wieder rauskommen. Weil sonst wird ja wieder alles viel zu lang und alle stöhnen. Deswegen denke ich mal, können wir das mit den beiden Themenblöcken diese Woche mal bleiben lassen. Alles, was unerwähnt ist, wird auf die nächste Woche gehoben. Wir sind so in der Hoffnung, dass wir die Themen dann auch etwas knapper behandeln können. Wenn auch nicht weniger ausführlich. Das war's.